yeah definitely
um K nearest neighbors is one of the
algorithms that we owe people working
with data know or at least should know
but it's also uh underrated algorithm
that it's not that popularly used uh in
production systems uh that's mostly
because uh there are some issues with
the with the performance of prediction
but there has been a lot of going on
with approximate nearest neighbor search
that is currently quite a Hot Topic and
today I would like to introduce one of
the algorithm that allowed us to bring
the approximation into nearest neighbors
so now it's way more performant than it
was before
what is the problem uh let's take this
example Toledo is a city in Spain and
these are the coordinates of the of the
city if I wanted to visit the city I
would probably take a plane and
definitely I would need to know what is
the closest airport to the to Toledo uh
so I would probably go to uh our April's
data just because I'm engineer and I
would probably uh start Reinventing the
wheel and create a system that will help
me to find the closest airport to the to
the Target City I could describe this
website and then simply by using over 70
000 operations I could find five closest
airports to Toledo what is the problem
here in order to do that I would need to
call the same function over 70 000 times
and probably that for for this case that
won't be an issue just because I would
do it once but if I wanted to have it
running as a service that anybody can
use I would have something like a full
table scan done for every single request
that I receive so definitely that's not
the way any kind of system should work
but there is a better way we can perform
the approximation because basically what
I did uh I was trying to find the
nearest neighbors uh given the
coordinates of the city
and as already mentioned k n is one of
the most underrated algorithms that was
purely a Canon search something that I
did before and that worked pretty well
only if we have a few examples of the
data but if we have a lot of samples
then things do not scale that well
and there has been a lot of going on uh
in terms of approximate nearest
neighbors that's obviously do not uh
assure us that we will receive as all
the closest points but with a proper
tunic we can uh we can be sure that at
least 1999 or whatever number we want uh
will be will be provided to us
so how does it work under the hood hnsw
that stands for hierarchical navigable
small words is an algorithm that targets
uh that solves the problem of
approximate nearest search
let's come back to the to the issue with
the uh with the airports that I had this
is uh limited limited collection of all
the airports around Europe uh I I didn't
really include all of them just because
all the map would be would be just
orange but still those are the major
ones and if I wanted to find the closest
one for a given City I would need to
just calculate the distance to every
single city of course just by looking at
the map I could probably select a
neighborhood area but for any machine
for any computer that won't be that easy
uh
so how do we solve that with hnsw hnsw
isager is an algorithm that is based on
graphs and uh there are many stacked
graph layers and this is the uh the top
layer number one when we where we just
put some of those uh some of those
points that we have in the original
collection that are selected to uh as
some kind of uh representation of of the
whole set and those are connected to
each other by their proximity in space
so only the airports which are really
close to each other should be connected
and
if we switch to the second layer of H to
the SW graph
here I just marked the point that I'm
looking for but if we just switch to the
second layer of the of the hnsw graph uh
uh we would
have
a lot of
different airports added but also those
ones that were present on the first
layer so there is an overlap between
those layers and right now we can
simply find the the the next airport
that is closer to the to the Target than
the one on the previous layer and that
goes down to the layer number three uh
where we have lots of of the airpods but
since we were just moving through the
graph in a greedy manner we could simply
find the closest point at each layer and
just uh search in its neighborhood at
the layer at the layer below uh that is
fairly easy idea but surprisingly it
allows us to uh scale that uh pretty
well and perform the search in sub
linear time
okay but uh definitely
looking for some closest points when it
comes to geocoordinates is not an issue
we have some different data structures
that targets that quite easily but there
is a topic of neural search quite uh
quite heavily promoted in the recent
years because it's it uh uses the the
Deep learning networks uh that are
capable of encoding literally any kind
of any kind of data into the latent
space and those uh those representations
typically called embeddings can be
compared to each other and the
assumption is that objects which are
close uh in the latent Spence space
should be also similar in reality
um so this is not only about latitude
and longitude for sure
so the embeddings are set are created by
Deep neural models uh there are a lot of
models available uh on the market so we
don't necessarily need to uh create our
own networks from scratch but we can
reuse some pre-trained models which are
available on a hugging phase or with
sentence Transformers those provide
state-of-the-art models which were
trained on some huge clusters and for
some tasks they even do not require any
kind fine tuning
so how does the hsw search work we start
at the top layer
and start with an entry point and try to
find the closest points to given query
uh then we switch to the layer uh below
to the layer one uh from the layer run
through the layer two and do basically
the same process starting with the
previous from the closest point from the
previous layer and that goes uh to the
uh from layer to layer there may be many
layers stacked on each other so that
actually performs the a similar process
like B trees or B plus trees in uh in
other indexes in relational databases
for instance
of course there are also some other
criteria that you typically need to
fulfill and in case of our lovely
airports uh it turns out that only one
of those uh ones which are the closest
only one of them is really open the
other ones are military airports or just
airports which are closed for ages so
definitely there are some additional
criteria that we would like to apply for
the Vector Research and that's
completely doable there is a way uh to
incorporate the face it at search
directly into the into the hnsw search
algorithm
so as a result we are able to select not
only the closest airport
uh which is uh definitely a different
one than the closest open airport so so
those criteria could be also fulfilled
and of course I do not
um
try to convince you to create your own
system for that purposes there are some
Vector databases that's how we call
those those tools and the quadrant
company that I work for is one of the
one of them this is an open source
Vector database with an interest
that uses uh hnsw with some extension to
perform the filtering directly into the
vector search space
we also have a cloud version but this is
an open source project so we can easily
start doing the vector search if you
want to
and if you would have any kind of
questions regarding Vector search or
hnsw or quadrons please feel free to
reach me out here is my email address
but you can also join our Discord
Channel I will be also present on the pi
data Global Discord so in case of any
questions feel free to reach me out
anytime you want
thank you very much